cinquante deux décès de plus depuis 24
heures au québec 2 139 cas de plus pour
les dessins on se garde évidemment une
petite gêne parce que des fois on fait
des ajustements en cours de semaine pour
des décès qui ont eu lieu quelques jours
avant karl weiss dr weiss est avec nous
président de l'association des médecins
microbiologiste-infectiologue du québec
bonsoir dr weiss regardons les courbes
rapidement ensemble si vous le voulez
bien
le nombre de décès on le voit la courbe
dix minutes ça c'est très très clair les
quotidiens qui sont rapportés la courbe
des minus et ressemble à une cloche
d'ailleurs de plus en plus on voit là la
tendance vers le bas et les
hospitalisations la même chose une
courbe qui est descendante
alors on est d'après vous pas sorti du
bois mais on est dans une période quand
même plus optimiste là alors oui
définitivement
donc qu'est-ce qu'il faut constater de
tout ça vous rappelez vous au début on
parlait quand est-ce qu'on attendra le
pic
on a atteint le pic mais vous avez vu
qu'on est resté longtemps sur le plateau
du pic et là on commence à descendre de
ce plateau dont s'était pas assommer
très acérées mais c'était bien un sommet
avec un long plateau dont on commence à
descendre et c'est encourageant
donc ça c'est le point le plus important
on s'aperçoit aussi que il ya eu quand
même encore beaucoup d c'est parce que
malheureusement même si on dit que le
nombre de décès diminue ses 52 personnes
qui sont quand même décédé de façon
quotidienne
troisièmement ben j'espère que là on va
tirer toutes les leçons et on aura un
peu de temps avant la prochaine vague
avant les prochaines 20 des vaguelettes
peu importe comment les appellera mais
il y en aura certainement des beaucoup
de leçons à tirer de tout cet
renseignements là pour essayer de
minimiser les impacts de qui ce de ce
qui va arriver plus tard
ça va nous permettre aussi peut-être
avec un certain répit de revenir avec
entre guillemets une vie un peu plus
normale sur plusieurs aspects on le voit
déjà dans les rues de montréal
mais je pense que c'est au moins
encourageants de ce côté là bon bien je
veux
je vous ai sorti une citation d'un
collègue médecin de parisiens qui
travaillent urgentiste à la pitié
salpêtrière docteur freud qui est qui a
fait quelques déclarations qui ont fait
réagir depuis début de la crise mais je
voulais vous faire réagir sur celle-là
l'épidémie dit il dans une entrevue au
point tel qu'on l'a connu il ya trois
mois et termine elle ne reprendra pas
l'élever du confinement il n'y aura pas
de deuxième vague cet été ni à la
rentrée dit il ça se poursuit
les régions sont principalement je suis
les réseaux sont principalement la
possible saisonnalité du virus qui
n'aiment pas le show et le temps sec
ainsi que l'immunisation de la
population qui freine beaucoup sa
circulation
alors ça c'est l'autre vision qui
existent aussi comment réconcilier
cette vision est ce que vous nous dites
par exemple écouter la vision c'est que
chacun peut avoir droit à ses opinions
mais la réalité même si on se réfère ou
h1n1 ce qui s'est passé en 2009 2010 on
a eu une vague au printemps et on a eu
une deuxième vague qui est arrivé à
l'automne si on se réfère aux événements
historiques qu'on va toujours avoir une
deuxième vague
peut-être bien plus qu'une deuxième
vague il faut savoir qu'il ya très peu
de population au québec qui est utilisé
actuellement contre ce virus là d'où
d'ailleurs l'importance d'avoir des
tests sérologiques pour avoir une idée
de la population qui protégeait con ce
virus là le québec actuellement est en
retard sur l'aspect des tests
sérologiques par rapport à d'autres
zones géographiques dans le monde et
donc falloir faire ça relativement
rapidement
mais comme on n'a pas beaucoup de gens
au québec qui sont protégés comme on
sait qu'on va commencer à ceux des
conflits nés qu'on va augmenter nos
contacts
même si on prend des précautions le port
du masque et cetera
la distanciation physique sylvain n'ont
néanmoins une vie qu'à la rentrée
scolaire au mois de septembre octobre
les enfants vont être mis beaucoup plus
proches les uns des autres les gens vont
commencent à retourner travailler on va
forcément aller
dans les restaurants on va peut aller
dans des endroits publics et à partir de
là la saisonnalité du virus va se
terminer
est-ce que la chaleur l'humidité ont un
rôle à jouer peut-être
il n'empêche que dans beaucoup de pays
chauds il ya également eu aussi beaucoup
de cas alors c'est pas c'est pas absolue
ça va peut-être je vois là certains
rôles mais rendu à l'automne cet aspect
de la chaleur cet aspect de la
température va disparaître et donc les
conditions pour un retour du virus dans
une population qui sera peu immune avec
plus de contacts par rapport à un des
confirmands font qu'on doit se préparer
alors si ce docteur la raison maintenant
mieux car mieux il faut qu'il sorte
qu'il faut se préparer au pire et
espérer finalement la meilleure
situation
donc c'est ça mais vous il n'y a pas de
certitude façon depuis le début il ya
plus de certitudes mais c'est une
probabilité quand même dit vous qu'une
deuxième vague
ben c'est une probabilité qu'on va avoir
d'autres vendent d'ailleurs dans des
pays qui ont été atteints avant nous on
peut pas trop se fier à ce qui se passe
en chine parce que les chiffres qui nous
proviennent de chine sont très peu
fiable parce que contrôler mais quand on
voit d'autres pays par exemple la corée
singapour
on voit aussi que des pays qui ont très
bien réussi où on commence à des
consignes et on voit tout de suite que
le nombre de cas commencent à augmenter
rapidement à certains endroits dont on
sait qu'il y aura des plus de 15 ans et
qui aura d'autres gens qui vont être
infectées
donc on peut pas complètement échappé à
cette deuxième vannes à moins évidemment
qu'on est un vaccin ce qu'on n'a pas et
n'oubliez pas fait quand on a eu le h1n1
on a eu une deuxième vague et on a eu un
vaccin en même temps mais est ce que
quand même docteur vous n'êtes pas
surpris de voir que depuis trois
semaines on a parlé jeudi dernier vous
et moi on a rouvert les écoles au québec
en france il ya quand même eu d'aidé
des réouvertures important et il n'y a
pas eu une accélération tant que ça
enfin il n'y a pas eu d' accélération de
cas en estrie à 0 qu'à peu près les
écoles sont ouverts depuis trois
semaines comment expliquer ça à la mais
vous savez on ne vit plus comme avant on
a un gars des signes de distanciation
cela beaucoup plus les mains à beaucoup
plus de gens par des masses d'ailleurs
il ya une étude qui vient de sortir qui
est dans le land 7 qui vient de montrer
les ita site est extrêmement crucial des
masques donc les masques je vous dire
vous écoutez moi rien il ya six mois
montréal aujourd'hui
vous avez beaucoup plus de monde qui se
promènent avec des masses donc il ya
quand même un ensemble de facteurs qui
font que
on n'est pas tout à fait dans le monde
d'avant vous savez les restaurants n'ont
pas rouvert à marjah vous voyez qu'on
essaie tranquillement il ya encore
beaucoup de commerces qui sont fermées
il ya un an même si vous voulez aller
chez le dentiste qui vient à peine de
réouvrir on s'aperçoit que la façon dont
les dentistes fonctionne n'a plus rien à
voir avec ce que ce fut dans le passé
donc un ensemble de facteurs qui font
qu'on n'a pas beaucoup de cas parce
qu'on n'est plus tout à fait dans le
mode de fonctionnement du passé c'est ça
mais si vous vous êtes persuadé que si
on trouverait trop rapidement
ça pourrait nous jouer de très mauvais
tour à ces sur écoute et si demain matin
en disant on ouvre les frontières comme
mois de janvier 2020 et que tout le
monde puisse aller n'importe où dans le
monde qu'on ne met personne en isolement
que les gens ne pas plus de masques qui
a plus de distanciation social que l'on
retrouve les écoles complètement les
universités et qu'on renvoie tout le
monde parlait dans les écoles qu'on
ouvre le centre bell et qui ont dit
d'avoir un match du canadien avec la
1000 personnes c'est clair qu'on va
avoir un nombre de cas qui va augmenter
très rapidement
je ne vois pas comment ça pourrait être
autrement très bien merci beaucoup pour
cette précision cette apprécié dr karl
weiss bonne soirée
merci encore une fois bonne soirée dans
la prochaine